so if you want to find hateful people
let me tell you where to find them
Twitter I'm just scrolling at the break
and this one's like I don't like that
you are so spiritual why don't you just
stick to money well let me help you with
that I can help you with that there's
two things you need to understand about
that number one I'll give you the
logical answer and then I'll give you
the smart on the cancer okay
the logical answer is that personal
finance is 80% behavior it's only 20%
had knowledge do you know where your
behaviors come from your spiritual
worldview your belief system is where
your behaviors come from and so if you
have a belief system that affects
behaviors in a positive way then it
should be tied into your personal
finance the problem with your Greek
methodology of thinking is is that it
compartmentalizes your life in a way
that is not how life is lived see you
don't get to break apart your
spirituality your money your marriage
your physical body you don't get to
break all of these your physical
condition your stress level your mental
health you don't get to break all of
these in neat little compartments they
are all interwoven in a tapestry and so
when you pull on one of the threads
darling it pulls on everything when you
straighten out your money the number of
people that lose weight while they're
getting out of debt is amazing it's not
because they're not eating it's because
they discovered this thing called
self-control when you pull on one of the
threads of the tapestry of your life it
affects the other parts of your life the
number of times I meet someone that says
we went through Financial Peace
University and saved our marriage that's
not a marriage class the sex class was
down the hall but what happened because
you're working on your money together
you increase communication you combined
your value systems
and when you share your dreams your
visions and your goals your marriage
increases and when you do a budget
you're forced to share your dreams in
your vision these things work together
personal finances behavior so to ignore
the spiritual and we can discuss
whichever spiritual angle you want I
happen to be an evangelical Christian
you might be an atheist or a Muslim or
whatever you are but if you ignore the
spiritual discussion as a part of a
subject that is 80% behavior that makes
you ignorant because it doesn't work
it's dumb
you can't do that it's it's it's
logistically practically impossible
because your worldview which is your
spiritual view affects every one of your
decisions whether you realize it or not
it changes everything
your view of morality of character it's
a spiritual view again your spiritual
view can be whatever you want to me I'm
not mad at you you can be whatever you
want to be and I'll help you I don't
care which were the brands or thing
you're tied up in I'll help you we don't
have to agree on Jesus for you to call
in hear me help you I'm here to help you
I'm gonna help you either way if you're
gonna be mad at me I'm just gonna block
you okay and I'm not gonna get on here
and argue with you that that's that's
the thing but but we're gonna help you
if you want help we're here to help you
and but you you know but you can't it's
intellectually insincere to address
something that is 80% behavior without
looking at it through the spiritual lens
it's just doesn't work it's impractical
it doesn't work now that's the real
answer the smart aleck answer is this is
called the Dave Ramsey show which means
I own it and I'm going to say whatever
the flip I want to say and if you don't
want to listen hit the Scan button baby
nobody's you're not paying me you know
you don't like it change the channel
vote with your finger eat meat meat meat
meat push the little button on your car
go somewhere else if you're offended but
your offense does not give you the right
to tell me how to run my business or the
content of this show your intolerance of
my tolerance is not okay with me
this is the Dave Ramsey show translation
it's about what I think and I'm an
expert on my opinion whatever you wanna
do kiddo
I don't care but you politically correct
morons that think you get to tell
everybody else what to do you can jump
in the frickin Creek okay you're
confused about how this works I get to
do what I want to do until none of you
are listening and then I might have
enough money to do it anyway so it's
okay
so far 15 million people aren't so angry
that they all left every week I may
manage to make them all mad and all of
you may leave eventually and I may not
be able to string a sentence together
because my brain quits working or
something that's okay that happens to
all of us eventually but as for today
this is who we is and it comes with the
package baby comes with the package you
don't get to slice and dice me this is
who is and we are not even a little bit
ashamed of that we love you and we're
gonna help you but you are confused if
you think you're gonna dictate the
content of this show you're seriously
confused I am too old and too much of a
hillbilly to be told what to do so just
doesn't work that way kiddo
sorry but I'm sorry you're offended but
just get in line there's a whole bunch
of you